this is a very sort of surprising way to
start today's show but there is now
speculation that donald trump is in
washington dc
and may be getting arrested or indicted
imminently now it is speculative but the
speculation is based on a previously
unannounced
seemingly last-minute trip that donald
trump made to washington d.c last night
newsweek reporting donald trump's
surprise visit to washington d.c sparks
arrest speculation
trump made a surprised and unannounced
visit to dc sunday prompting speculation
and rumors about the reason for his trip
the video of trump arriving at dulles
airport in virginia an airport
frequently used by those heading to the
capitol was posted online by freelance
reporter andrew lydon trump can be seen
getting out of a plane heading into a
vehicle trump appears to be wearing golf
shoes and a white polo top now
we're getting into details that seem so
trivial but there have already been
counterpoints that it appears to be a
golf uh his golf shoes but those are not
actually shoes trump wears to golf and
thus the idea is he is not just showing
up to golf or necessarily coming from
the golf course uh but trump does stay
at his golf courses when he fl travels
around if there's one available
and the motorcade then uh is believed to
have gone in the direction of one of
trump's golf courses now there is video
of what took place and there are a
number of very strange things in the
video
we're going to play it see if you can
spot some of them then i'll mention a
couple of things that i notice and that
others have noticed as well
we see donald trump coming off the plane
holding something
not totally clear what he is holding
and getting into a vehicle
is making its way off and then this is
at 6 31 pm
and then they drive away
one of the really really strange things
that was pointed out is that it sort of
looks like trump is carrying a bottle of
ketchup
a bottle of ketchup
which is an extraordinarily strange
thing for a president a former president
to be carrying
but it might be something else could be
a maga hat folded up or who knows what
it is so there's a couple of different
things going on here first of all
do we really know why he's in dc we
don't
do we know that it is an unexpected and
unplanned trip up until the last moment
we do because there generally is
awareness of the
soon-to-be whereabouts of the former
president
one explanation would be some kind of
medical issue certainly a possibility a
second possibility
he's he's back to be reinstated as
president of the united states
uh not one i believe is likely but there
are already the sort of q people and
conspiracy people that are speculating
along these lines already
and number three is that it has
something to do with the federal
investigation against him um
for he's in there in the city for
meetings that were previously
undisclosed based on who knows what is
going on okay fine um this is strange
there are a number of strange things
here for people who understand sort of
protocol and the amount of information
that is known ahead of time about where
donald trump plans to be this is
certainly unusual now for those who are
continuing to have this idea
of the perp walk the perp walk that at
some point may happen if donald trump is
indicted i don't think it makes sense to
hold our breaths for that as i've said
before every indication that if indeed
donald trump is going to be indicted
that there is going to be a sort of
coordinated handoff involving secret
service and that there is not going to
be the perp walk that many of us
admittedly would love to see of donald
trump at some point in time but no
shortage of the conspiracy people
immediately jumping to he is back to be
declared president by i don't know the
newly anointed king charles iii or who
the hell knows what that is not what
donald trump is in washington dc for
you now know everything that is known to
us as of this moment and by the time
today's episode goes live by the time
this clip gets up on youtube and
facebook and elsewhere since it takes a
couple of hours for us to turn the show
around there may be more known and we
will then follow up about it plastic is
everywhere we look and not enough is
being done about it 100 billion plastic
bags are used and thrown away every year
but you can help make a change our
sponsor hold on
makes trash and kitchen bags that are
heavy-duty plant-based non-toxic and 100
home compostable which means they break
down in weeks rather than decades they
don't fill up our landfills they don't
pollute our oceans their zip seal
kitchen bags come in sandwich or gallon
bag sizes to fit your needs and the best
part about hold on bags is they work i
use them at home they're just as good as
all of the name brand bags you fill them
up they stretch and they don't break
everybody uses trash bags and freezer
bags if you care about the planet you
can do something by using hold on bags
instead and it's a really easy way to do
your part to shop plant-based bags and
replace single-use plastics all over
your home go to
holdonbags.com and you'll save 20
percent with the code pacman at checkout
the link is down below